today a seven billion dollar money
laundering service just got shut down by
the united states many crypto advocates
say this is an attack against their
privacy while crypto skeptics say
it's about time as for my opinion i'm
torn about tornado cash let me explain
tornado cash is a website and smart
contract that would describe itself as a
privacy tool many people like myself who
investigate fraud though have seen it
used primarily as a money laundering
tool but what's the truth well tornado
cash is a bit of code that has one job
it takes your money in and hides where
it's going it does this by mixing it
together with a bunch of other people's
money thereby making it untraceable
hence why tornado cash is called a
crypto mixer which obviously if you're a
criminal sounds very appealing because
think about it on a blockchain where
everything is traceable and public
tornado cache represents a break in that
chain which is why anytime there's a
hack like for example the 620 million
dollar axi infinity hack you'll usually
hear the name tornado cash getting
thrown around because that's how
criminals hide their funds and because
it's used by criminals so much the us
treasury put tornado cash on a special
list called the sdn list which is the
ultimate banned list it's what russian
oligarchs go on the ultimate blacklist
at a party except that party is the
global financial system and what it
means is that everyone's forbidden from
interacting with people or things on
this list which means if you now send
money to tornado cash you could be
liable as a criminal and be put in jail
for up to 30 years and so far all this
makes sense right who doesn't want to
put the bad guys away and stop them but
what makes this story very tricky is
that while the us government implies
that only criminals use tornado cash
that just isn't true anyone who wants to
conceal their money
might want crypto mixers and it isn't
just the bad guys in fact according to
chain alice's ten percent of the funds
sent to tornado cash were stolen another
17
came from sanctioned sources which
probably is a bit conservative but even
so that means that 27 of these funds are
essentially criminal but then the rest a
lot of it is not criminal so why would a
normal person need to use tornado cash
well assuming most of us are past the
fifth grader argument of if you have
nothing to hide why do you need privacy
it basically boils down to wanting the
government and society out of your house
your life and of course your money which
is why there are many pro-privacy
arguments to be made in favor of tornado
cash and why it was helpful like just
ask yourself assuming a crypto future
where everything is on chain do you
really want anyone to be able to see
everything you buy do you really want
that anime body pillow to be public
information do you want your donation to
a dissident political figure to be
public do we really think that
governments can always be trusted
obviously the answer to all of those is
no so now that we've gone over the
negatives and positives of crypto mixers
what do we do well the answers aren't
easy because while crypto used to be the
wild wild west if you actually expect
regular people and grandmas to use it
you have to take the scam and fraud
problem really seriously and tornado
cash is a huge part of that problem you
can't just expect the government to sit
back and watch as billions of dollars
get sent through untraceable pools of
money so there's a balance i think we're
heading for like it or not and to be
honest it's not perfect but here it is
you fundamentally need the government to
be able to investigate crime and you
also need privacy for your citizens but
ultimately this is not a binary it's a
balance because this doesn't work if it
goes too far in either direction if the
government can just surveil people all
the time theoretically they could fight
crime perfectly but nobody wants a
surveillance state and on the other
extreme if the government could never
investigate a crime because everyone had
maximum privacy crime rates would
skyrocket and nobody wants that future
either so the balance has to be a
reasonable expectation of privacy but if
you're implicated in a crime law
enforcement has to be able to
investigate it and this is already how
most of the world works your banks for
example the government can't just search
your accounts they need evidence and
they need a warrant so you have a
reasonable expectation to privacy but
it's not perfect privacy and that's sort
of the problem with tornado cash is that
it's too good at its job there are no
warrants available for tornado cash no
investigation tools nothing that can
trace funds sent through a mixer that
money is gone even if you can 100 prove
that it was stolen which is why i think
the banning of tornado cash was
inevitable like it or not the dream of
perfect privacy just can't co-exist in a
world where criminals will abuse that
perfect privacy for fraud and scams now
right as i was going to finish this
video i did discover a final m night
shyamalan twist to this whole saga the
users of tornado cash have started to
get a little sassy and started sending
tiny amounts of eth to a ton of wallets
including famous wallets like jimmy
fallon steve aoki and logan paul
presumably to make it so difficult to
figure out who's the real money
launderer is that it becomes impossible
to implicate anyone now will all these
crypto influencers go to jail for 30
years for this no obviously not but it
is pretty funny and it shows that they
can take away your right to buy an anime
body pillow in private they can take
away your right to money launder in
private but they can never take away
your sense of humor about it